[Music]
anthos is Google clouds new open
platform that lets you run an app
anywhere simply flexibly and securely
with anthos we bring the cloud to you as
an enterprise you need to move faster
the expected time to market for products
and services has shortened dramatically
from years to days with the growth of
mobile clients you are now serving
hundreds to billions of users
concurrently rather than making copies
on disks but today you move at the speed
of your slowest developer cloud as a way
to put the pedal down the cloud is
wonderful for people who are building
everything from scratch but you might
have decades of investment in your
existing data centers you're forced into
making trade-offs security versus
agility reliability versus cost
portability versus consistency the news
is you don't have to move to the cloud
today moving to a micro services
architecture you can let each team work
at the speed that suits them believe it
or not Google started out this way too
and we have a lot of investment in
datacenters changing the way we wrote
our applications meant we could move
quicker and scale out to more locations
to serve our global customer base along
the way we pioneered a thing called a
container containers are a way of
bundling an application for deployment
on the server if you write software in
something like Java you might do this
today instead of using an application
server like Tomcat or WebSphere and
bundling your application into a jar
file you build your application into a
container and run it on a container
runtime normally an application server
handles clustering load balancing and
resource management for you but that's
only for applications on the JVM
containers on the other hand run
directly on the operating system kernel
meaning you can put any application in
them you don't need to have a different
deployment system for absent in
different languages or binary is versus
things you've built for source now you
just need an application server to run
these containers and that's where
kubernetes comes in kubernetes deals
with all the stuff that your application
server worried about and it does so in a
declarative way you tell it what you
want to run and make sure that you
always have what you asked for
you can think of kubernetes is the
kernel of the new distributed
application platform as
all software you need to install manage
and operate your kubernetes environment
you need to manage the nodes through
things like kernel and operating system
upgrades the manual management of
communities can be resource intensive so
in 2015 we launched google kubernetes
engine in the cloud gke allows users to
focus on clusters rather than
administration and now people have come
back and said I want gke but in my data
center so we've taken it a step further
GK on-prem is gke running in your data
center it's managed by Google's
world-class engineering team but it runs
on your own Hardware behind your
firewall and integrates with your
existing networking storage and identity
systems you can build your own apps into
containers you can deploy any container
image from a public repository or you
can deploy a variety of supported
applications using the GCP marketplace
whatever you want to do GK young PM lets
you deploy in scale and seconds hundreds
of times a day and potentially increase
resource utilization by up to 75 percent
kubernetes alone isn't enough it helps
you run applications but you still have
to manage them you need to handle
Identity and Access Management for those
applications and debug your clusters
when things go wrong on top of that your
teams are looking at cloud and seeing
the new service offerings so Google has
launched anthos a single platform for
running wherever you are
modernization journeys can be daunting
but with the power of open software
orchestration and containerization
Google brings you the power to modernize
both on-premises as well as in the cloud
while moving at a pace you are
comfortable with to learn more about
kubernetes and gke
please subscribe to our Channel
you